ich glaube jeder ob am stammtisch oder
in
politischen kreisen ob in der familie
mit den kindern oder
unter freunden diskutiert glaube ich
jeder jetzt wo führt das hin also wie
geht das aus wofür das sind und gibt es
eigentlich noch einen plausiblen ausweg
aus der
dauerhaften krisen um nicht zu sagen
kriegssituation und wenn man es dreht
und wendet glaube ich dass ein punkt
sein kann der bisher ab und zu mal
genannt wird ich glaube nur die
neutralität der ukraine liefert
überhaupt noch eine möglichkeit für
frieden und das ist eine ziemlich
brutale sache weil die ukraine natürlich
zu recht sagt wir wollen ins westliche
bündnis wir wollen in die nato wir
wollen in die eu das alles von all
diesen wünschen und forderungen und
vorstellungen müsste die ukraine
zurücktreten warum weil dann auf der
anderen seite wladimir putin der als
einen seiner kings gründe die
neutralität der ukraine und die
demilitarisierung entmilitarisierung der
ukraine genannt hat sozusagen zustimmen
kann und schon wenn man das sagt uns mw
müssen wir jetzt dinge in betracht
ziehen denen wladimir putin der
kriegstreiber der touran der despot der
kriegsverbrecher zustimmen kann ich
fürchte am ende ist dass die bedingung
um in eine friedliche zukunft gehen zu
können das modell dafür ist das modell
österreich österreich hat 1955 sich zu
einer neutralität bekannt also wäre es
nicht ein weg in die zukunft die ukraine
mit dem modell österreich und der
neutralität in kontakt zu bringen ein
weg in die zukunft der uns allen dann
die möglichkeit gebe das als ich sage
jetzt bewusst nicht kriegsziel sondern
als einigungs ziel anzustreben
[Musik]
ja also als österreicher gibt es mir da
alle auch krämpfe zusammen wenn ich das
höre dass die ukraine nach
österreichischem vorbild überleben soll
das problem ist das wird sie nicht
dazu muss man auch sagen das modell
neutralität lag schon am tisch also wir
haben ja als dem militär aufmarsch zu
diesem krieg stattfand mehrere monate
gehabt wo verschiedene kanzler
präsidenten versucht haben zu vermitteln
versucht haben zu verhandeln wo sie
längst selber auch viele punkte auf den
tisch gebracht hat die putin von einem
krieg hätte abbringen können hätte er
den krieg nicht gewollt und nur diesen
krieg gewollt um die ukraine zu
unterwerfen eine davon war die frage ob
man auf den nato-beitritt verzichten
würde das problem ist russland gibt sich
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt mit so einer
neutralität nicht zufrieden es will eine
entwaffnete neutralität eben eine
österreichische weil österreich
militärisch während des ganzen krieg
kalten krieges schwach war es wird sogar
über die österreichische neutralität
hinausgehen in österreich fallen in
seiner anfangszeit
amerikanische militär unterstützung
hatte wir hatten sehr viel vor im
militär eade wir hatten unsere ganzen
offiziere der ersten generation in den
usa ausgebildet und wir hatten sehr
intensive kontakte vor allen dingen mit
der nato in italien also österreich
hätte zum kriegsschauplatz süd gehört im
fall eines eines totalen krieges
zwischen der nato und dem warschauer
pakt und wir hatten sehr starke
verbindung mit unseren italienischen
kollegen weil wir sozusagen dann im
kriegsfall denen unterstanden wehren
dass auch das lehnt putin ab er will
eine verteidigungs lose ukraine eine wir
diesen krieg zu jeder sekunde und für
jedes interesse das sind gerade durch
den kopf geht sofort unter besseren
bedingungen wieder fortsetzen kann als
er ihn jetzt führt und das ist das
problem
oder das ist der grund warum die ukraine
das zurecht ablehnt wenn die ukraine aus
diesem krieg hervor geht und wie sie aus
diesem ukraine aus diesem krieg
hervorgeht es gibt zwei bedingungen
erstens sie ist souverän die regierung
der präsident wird vom ukrainischen volk
bestimmt und von niemand anderem und das
zweite sie ist wehrhaft in welcher form
auch immer aber das wäre ja das werden
ja zwei bedingungen die wird auf den
tisch müssen jetzt sagen sie zu recht
putin wird sich damit nicht zufrieden
geben mit dem argument allerdings kann
man praktisch gar nichts anbieten mit
dem argument bleibt er die situation der
ukraine ich formuliere ist jetzt mal aus
der position des freundes der ukraine
bleibt sie
auch eine art drohung an den westen
nämlich entweder ihr seid schuld daran
dass wir untergehen oder wir ziehen euch
in eine nicht mehr kalkulierbare
eskalation das ist ja im grunde dass das
ist ja die ansage von selensky mehr oder
weniger auf deutsch übersetzt und ich
finde dass dieser weg wehrhaft und
selbstbestimmt also selbstbewusst
zwischen den blöcken das finde ich ein
modell das sich noch nicht aufgeben
würde
vielleicht denkt wladimir putin im
angesicht der kriegshandlungen auch noch
mal neu auf was anderes kann man ja gar
nicht setzen weil sonst kann man sich
ihm gleich ergeben hat sie mir es ist
ein modell was man denken könnte was
klar strom sigrid krebs gezählt
die zeit ist vorbei und dieses diese
idee von claus strunz hat einen fehler
sie unterstellt es gibt zwei aggressive
teile zwei parteien die sich
gegenüberstehen beide aggressiv sind und
beide sich überfallen worden das ist
nicht richtig es gibt einen aggressiven
start unter der führung von putin nicht
das russische volk aber die russische
regierung die ihrem einfluss durch
expansion durch aggression geld machen
will und es gibt einen selbst
verteidigungsbündnis das heißt nato er
hat es ist doch absurd herrscht uns dass
die nato oder der eu dass staaten aus
diesem verbund russland angreifen wollen
dass lettland estland das baltikum polen
russland überfallen oder die ukraine
moskau marschiert das ist absurd er hat
auch keine angst vor einer militärischen
bedrohung sondern er hat einst vom
verlust seiner wirkungsmacht in dieser
region dass er eben nicht militärisch
handeln kann und ich will es ihnen noch
an einem andern also in allen an einem
anderen beispiel sagen wir glauben daran
dass staaten selbst bestimmt sind dass
regierungen frei gewählt werden müssen
und wenn ein staat sich entscheidet sich
diesem oder jenem bündnis anzuschließen
dann haben dass die anderen staaten zu
respektieren und das polen
beispielsweise in selbstbestimmung sich
der eu der nato anschließt ist das gute
recht des polnischen volkes übrigens
wäre ist auch das gute recht wieder aus
eu und nato auszutreten in diesem falle
würde ja wenn man putins argumentation
folgt hätte die nato hätte die
bundesrepublik eine recht in polen ein
zu streiten weil man sagen würde polen
wird nicht mehr zum bündnis hat gute
beziehung zu russland wir fühlen uns
bedroht das gibt nicht was gerade
passiert ist die neutralität eines
staates die immer 1 gehabt haben von
russland überfallen zu werden von moskau
beeinflusst zu werden und das wird nicht
deswegen ist der eingang und das kann
die wertegemeinschaft der wir angehören
nicht akzeptieren ok ich kann ihre
argumentation folgen ich finde sie in
weiten teilen überzeugend aber was folgt
aus ihr außer die totale unterwerfung
unter putin wir reden nur über die
ukraine wir reden nicht über er betritt
nato gebiet dann haben wir ja klare
verhältnisse wir reden über die zukunft
der ukraine der menschen dort die jetzt
millionenfach aus dem land fliehen
müssen was ist unser angebot was ist
unser jetzt sage ich es doch was ist
unser kriegsziel einigungs ziel als
westen als deutschland was legen die auf
den tisch ich sage die neutralität wäre
ein erstrebenswertes ziel die hürden
sind mir klar sie sagen die zeit ist
drüber weg gegangen aber welche zeit ist
dann jetzt angebracht geben wir die
frage doch mal zu paul in kiew paul du
hast doch bestimmt los zu antworten
ja klaus dürfte tatsächlich die größte
frage und das größte problem auf ich
will vielleicht mal aus ukrainischer
perspektive sagen warum ist so schwierig
ist für die ukraine überhaupt in
irgendeine verhandlung zu gehen oder
irgendetwas zu unterschreiben wenn das
denn aus teamsicht möglich wäre 1994
wurde der ukraine eine
sicherheitsgarantie gegeben und zwar
schon russland und dem westen im
gegenzug hat die ukraine die atomwaffen
abgegeben das vergessen immer viele
ursprünglich war die ukraine genauso wie
russland eine atommacht die wurden 1994
abgegeben weil man gesagt hat wir werden
euch niemals angreifen
wir sehen diese garantie hat zu nichts
geführt das heißt all das was jetzt
kommt wenn man sagen würde okay es ist
eine dermaßen eine militärische
übermacht auf russischer seite wir sind
bereit hier neutralität zu geben wobei
das innenpolitisch ein riesiges problem
wäre weil viele viele menschen das nicht
wollen aber nehmen wir an man würde das
machen wie kann man denn putin vertrauen
das er sagt okay ich gehe da nicht rein
ich mach das nicht wer wer soll ihm denn
vertrauen das er in einem halben jahr
das nicht tut oder im nächsten jahr das
das ist das große problem dass große den
er macht aber ich gebe klaus recht was
ist dann die lösung ich muss sagen ich
habe keine antwort darauf ob diese und
ich finde und war deshalb auch weil ganz
kurz ein letzter satz weil wladimir
putin ja sagt die ukraine gibt es gar
nicht das ist alles russland also ich ja
das ist das dilemma gar keine frage aber
ich frage mich auch wenn die menschen in
der ukraine sagen wir wollen diese
neutralität nicht sondern wir wollen
dass der westen uns hilft laden sie auch
eine große moralische verantwortung auf
ihren schultern denn das bedeutet wenn
wir sterben sollen solltet ihr im westen
auch sterben denn ihr sollt dann in
diese kriegerische handlung eintreten
diese forderung liegt ja auf dem tisch
lasst uns nicht allein ihr müsst uns
helfen ihr müsst luft die die den
luftraum sperren das bedeutet ein
eingriff der nach internationalen
gesetzmäßigkeiten gedeutet werden kann
als sozusagen die nächste
eskalationsstufe und auf die wartet
wladimir putin uhr also glaube ich dass
man dem gedanken der neutralität zu
schmerzhaft er sein mag und die klinke
ist natürlich kann man einem mann
vertrauen der ein gerade überfallen hat
der gerade die brüder die schwestern die
kinder die eltern
töten lässt kann man dem vertrauen die
antwort liegt auf der hand nein aber was
bleibt sonst und das hat mich zu dem
gedanken gebracht von allen optionen
dritter weltkrieg durch
eskalation ukraine geht unter unter
russischer herrschaft irgendwelche neuen
grenzen werden gemacht und putin hat
gewonnen gefällt mir irgendwie die idee
wenn man das so sagen darf dass sich die
rivalität noch mal einen einen weg bahnt
der gedanke der neutralität noch am
allerbesten aus unserer sicht
wenn du aber dann möchte ich eine
gegenfrage aufstellt
aber nicht nur die ukraine ich würde
bezweifle ich würde bezweifeln dass
selbst wladimir putin das akzeptieren
würde wie soll er denn sagen in er hat
in seinen reden in seiner letzten
ansprache ganz klar gesagt die ukraine
gehört zu russland das bedeutet ja er
will sie sich einverleiben und sie soll
in dem sinne kein staat bleiben dann
würde ja bleiben putin auf die
neutralität nicht reichen klaus
also wenn man nicht daran glaube letzter
gedanke wenn man nicht daran glaubt dass
man wladimir putin etwas hinlegen kann
was ihnen vielleicht interessieren
könnte diplomatisch als politischen
erfolg ich komme ja immer von diesem
furchtbaren gedanken dass er sein
gesicht wahren können muss nach der
auseinandersetzung interessiert mich
eigentlich gar nicht ob ein mörder und
kriegsverbrecher sein gesicht wahren
kann aber es scheint mir der einzige
ausweg zu sein dann müssen alle die
sagen neutralität ist keine option doch
was anderes auf tischen und sagen dann
lasst es uns so versuchen und das habe
ich noch nicht erkannt ich würde mich
auch ich sage es jetzt flapsig schock
für lieben wenn ein anderes modell
dessen wir so plausibel erschienen wie
die neutralität die schwierig genug ist
den krieg erst einmal verlieren oder
zumindest so großen schaden nehmen dass
er sich mit dem über mit der realität
überhaupt ab findet dass er einen ausweg
braucht denn zurzeit geht ja nur auf die
maximalforderungen auf eine totale
entwaffnung der ukraine und das kann
kann nicht das ziel sein und dann ist es
auch so die ukraine braucht die ukraine
kann nicht auf treu und glauben spielen
die ukraine braucht eine wehrhafte
situation in der sie sich verteidigen
kann ob sie sich durch allianz mit
anderen verteidigen kann oder ob sie
genauso wie das im fall jugoslawiens
nach 1948 war wie das im fall österreich
nach 1950 war wobei österreich hat zu
dem guten teil versammelt und das später
nochmal teuer gekommen aber ist eine
andere geschichte die in österreich
interessiert oder ob das etwas schweden
war im kalten krieg oder die schweiz aus
einer selbst verteidigungsfähigkeit und
bei vielen neutralen staaten die vorher
angesprochen habe eine unterstützte
selbst verteidigungsfähigkeit die usa
haben 1956 als die russischen panzer
durch budapester wollten sofort eine
garantie ausgesprochen dass jede
verletzung österreichs unmittelbare
militärische konsequenzen durch die usa
hervorrufen sie haben nuklear
bewaffneten flugzeuge nach mitteleuropa
verschickt die service haben das sofort
verstanden das hat niemand für die
ukraine gemacht und wenn man es wenn
sich der westen dann auch nicht bewusst
ist was es bedeutet einem bündnis freien
hoch verwundbaren staat hier zu haben
dann können wir alle papierform in der
neutralität über den buckel schmeißen
und weil potente das papier nicht
interessiert interessiert knacken meine
panzer das oder nicht